foreign
[Music]
time for marketing move on first up the
popular cooking competition show the
Great British Bake Off
it's going woke and mixing country
themed weeks in the new season because
viewers were offended by racial jokes
stereotypes cultural inaccuracies in
past episodes
Andrew I always like hearing these
stories about people were offended and
you never know who these people are
right right it's just like they were mad
about the Japan week or something who
actually has the time to get mad over
this stuff I mean from a culinary
perspective I was mad because like when
it was Japan week everybody made chow
mein and lo mein yes so it's like come
on right yeah and and the hosts were
behind us as well first of all nobody
should be hosting a food show except me
I mean let's just make that clear uh so
that's first and foremost but the hosts
were really bad on this they thought
they were funny but you know some of
their jokes weren't great but the hosts
themselves you know they even said that
the most exotic they got when it came to
food was actually having lunch at Panda
Express so I just don't think there was
much you know diversity of thought that
went into this I was so disappointed
that they weren't serving panda
well yeah you're right you're right
false advertising false Average Joe this
is a cooking show in Britain that's like
having a show about teeth in Britain
they're not known for their food but
I'll tell you what I don't understand
all the fake outrage about this two
white hosts are wearing some barrels but
they're doing it because it's they're
trying to celebrate a culture it's a bit
of a cliche but they're not trying to
like disparage anybody or yeah or take
any work away from mariachi bands the
reason mariachi bands are jobless is
because nobody likes mariachi bands
see an attack on the mariachi bands
coming into this segment uh yeah he was
laying those tracks early on in the show
how fun is married
[Laughter]
out of the way now my favorite was
Taliban Taliban week
[Laughter]
made exploding cakes well they just cut
each other's hands off so no one could
cook
somebody's stole ingredients listen this
fake outrage I want names in a picture
and a video yeah like when you you've
got to it has to be a minute long you
have to carry this at least a minute
because no it's the same thing always
happens a producer in the back saw their
chance the woke one one to push their
ideals so you know what you did you just
canceled your show I don't know how many
years it's been running
goodbye once you woke it it's done it's
broke because there's no woke audience
and then they'll be like what happened
what happened then they'll know outrage
doesn't know feelings because they just
ruined the show if a white guy wears no
Mexican called in just like if they had
hats backwards and gold chains for
southern food week yeah you know what
I'm saying and lo and behold they were
making uh watermelon souffles and fried
chicken I'm sure they'll be like
somebody's outrage look at Joe he's
Furious no Mariachi so
and no one would care but there would be
one of them who was it always is their
secret identities that come out it's
always the most racist dude that's the
liberal and it's always a person that
has all the problems that's a liberal
who then tells on himself like we got to
stop this
you wearing those sombreros everyone
thinks this is Taco Bell like no one
thought that it's always the liberal
that brings out all the racism I do I
have to say
you know
they did go too far on the Mexican theme
show cat they made a burrito large
enough to conceal three illegal
immigrants
yeah
so yeah
I've never seen this show neither have I
ever but yeah I don't like do the whole
cooking thing and I thought that's why I
didn't like to watch the cooking shows
but then I realized I watched like a lot
of murder shows and I don't do that
whole thing either but I feel like in
general if you are if to tyrus's point
if you are finding yourself sitting
there watching a cooking show and
getting real pissed yeah
everyone in your life is right about you
yeah it
need to calm down yeah it's it's sad
that we now run we're in a society where
like five people can destroy a career or
a job or anything or maybe you're hungry
yeah
it's such a great point cat I can't
believe I'm throwing my hat on the
ground
there's 1 500 channels now
push last and move on with your night
they should have oh they should have
awoke Network how fun they do it's
called CNN Plus
I haven't seen the numbers yet but I
heard the numbers are shocking all right
we've got to move on a husband is
creating a debate about whether you
should wait for your spouse at the gate
or board a plane and take off without
them if they don't make it in time the
anonymous traveler explained it a Reddit
post that his wife went to buy coffee at
the very last minute just as boarding
was about to start he wanted to he
wanted to wait as long as he could and
called her several times but no answer
so he boarded without her and the plane
left and she missed the flight and had
to get on the next one and the next one
crashed and she died
that's the last part is false
I was I was wish casting
which means he made a great choice yeah
I do but I mean I'm sorry who okay I
think it was I think it was a Joe who
made this put I can't remember but like
the gall of somebody going to get coffee
at the last minute is just pisses me off
this is the most sexist this is a sexist
story we need 7 000 Sexes coming up
because if it's a woman who says well
Tyrus went to get coffee so we got on
the plane nobody would have a problem
with it
I get to the airport two hours early
yeah
yeah don't get coffee within that hour
and hour and E5 before
my family knows I'm the first one on I
wait for the pre order we know
everyone's in a wheelchair with dirty
shoes don't fall for that
[Applause]
yeah thank you that's all I'm checking
I'm like the shoes are dirty lazy I'm so
gonna say that next time I'm there I do
it all the time just look for it you've
seen with dirty shoes give them a look
yeah yeah
just make sure you check the shoes first
before you go but I'm on if you're not
with me hey catch this there's another
one coming I'll get to the hotel you get
car service but uh yeah I'm not missing
them I don't miss planes neither do I I
hate it I'm just wondering which one
would do which like with cat and cam
would you leave if he was if he did this
or would or would he leave if you did
this well to tyrus's point actually if I
did this and left him that would be
would be okay but if he did it to me it
would not be okay
but it's true ever since I got married
I'm just on complete autopilot at the
airport I don't know where my gate is I
don't know where I'm going uh like
someone will be like man you're boarding
pass I'm like did I know
that's his job to be worried about but
no I get stressed I need to get there
early as soon as I land for like a
vacation I'm like we probably should
just stay here so we don't miss our
flight home I get I'm pretty bad about
that I used to get hotels next to the
airport and also why do you drink coffee
before a flight exactly like like why I
said you know maybe want to be awake so
you don't miss anything I know it
doesn't no airplanes are for Downers yes
and the coffee's free and you might get
diarrhea always yep yep we've seen that
oh yeah whole audience has never had
diarrhea yeah Amazing by the way they
showed the tape of the Delta that's oh
my God
storming I'm not joking
Joe you are let's say in polite terms a
womanizer you're with a different woman
every week so is this some something
with that happens to you when you fly
with the girls when you take them to
your Resorts and stuff uh Greg uh I
would I divorce her if she wanted me to
wait at a regular Starbucks okay
[Laughter]
you're gonna be exhausted from love
making
Starbucks and and wait in a half hour
every day they're called caffeine pills
look into them all right
that's weird I'll make love to you like
you're like I'm a gay fitness instructor
and yes the background music is a
mariachi band
all right Chef gruel uh where do you
stand on this issue well you know what
it's funny so I've got four kids right
when we travel it's kind of an unspoken
thing that it's pure all-out Anarchy
yeah there are no rules my wife and I do
this to each other all the time oh I
gotta go to the bathroom really quickly
that's because I don't want to deal with
pulling four kids down the Jet Bridge or
whatever the hell that's called you know
and then we get on the plane so I would
totally expect this from my wife whether
it's coffee or what have you right it
wouldn't be coffee because we both have
irritable bowel syndrome but you know
the the reality is is that there when
you get on a plane rules don't apply
look at what happens when a plane lands
people get up I saw some guy cross body
block a 91 year old the other day for
the last Savory snack mix yeah no it's
great people suspend all decency oh
because it's like because if they assume
you're never going to see them again
yeah right so why not be rude unless
you're diarrhean all over the aisle like
that last one
also called gut Felding all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else